let's talk about how you can actually
boost testosterone just with consuming
more onions and of course testosterone
is definitely a problem with men as they
get older by the time you reach 40 every
year your testosterone decreases by one
percent and testosterone does many
things Beyond just increasing libido
it's in control of male characteristics
like hair on your body it's also
involved in muscle there are quite a few
people that are also going the
testosterone route and getting
testosterone pellets and taking
testosterone injections things like that
which I'm not crazy about those
therapies simply because anytime you
start taking a hormone you inactivate
the gland that makes that hormone so my
question is why would you need to
increase the hormone in the first place
what's actually causing a decrease in
that hormone generally speaking a much
better approach would be or glandular
therapy supporting the gland with
certain nutrition or even whole
desiccated glandulars because that way
you're supporting the thing that can
communicates not necessarily the
communication between the gland and the
receptor because really the endocrine
system is a communication Network very
similar to neurotransmitters that work
through the nervous system so hormones
are created sent through the blood and
get received to create different effects
and so when you tend to bypass Mother
Nature it always comes with a problem or
a side effect but in this video I'm
going to talk just about something that
won't have any side effects onions now
what does an onion do for testosterone
well apparently there's something in the
onion that triggers another hormone
called luteinizing hormone from the
pituitary
and luteinizing hormone in males travels
down to the testicles to increase
testosterone so luteinizing hormone is
kind of like the controller or regulator
of the production of testosterone and
onion based in about 29 different uh
studies was about 75 percent effective
onions also give you a lot of additional
things it has properties to help with
insulin resistance it gives powerful
antioxidant effects it's anti-cancer it
can increase nitric oxide which can help
your vascular system but they have
isolated one compound in onion called
quercetin and out of all 28 vegetables
that were studied onions had the highest
amount of this compound and so they've
tested this compound and they found that
it does increase luteinizing hormone it
also helps the body decreasing risk of
getting cataracts allergies it's good
for cancer it's a potent
anti-inflammatory it can help decrease
blood pressure and it's also a direct
credit so the best way to get this
compound curcitin out of the onion is to
consume it as raw as possible now of
course you're still going to get some if
you saute the onion or even cook it as
long as you don't overcook it so here's
some really practical ideas and how to
get more onions in your diet I always
like to cut a slice of onion on my
hamburger and my eggs sometimes I do
grilled onions in different dishes I use
onions in guacamole and salsa sometimes
I put in my salad I put it in my soups
so there's many different ways to do
this and it's a real simple no-brainer
way to indirectly increase your
testosterone through increasing the
quercetin but there's many other ways to
increase or boost testosterone and if
you haven't seen this video on
testosterone it's essential I put it up
right here